what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to rollo tamasi um he is
coming for it looks like
i think based on the title one of my
favorite content creators like on the
planet i love jordan peterson so it'll
be interesting to see if i agree or
disagree with rolo because i think some
things that he says are very wise and
there's other stuff that like
it's kind of odd to me but before i
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos i am moving to england
in a couple weeks so each and every one
of you subscribing really helps me
support the channel on top of that i'm
actually doing like a new camera um for
this video so let me know if you guys
like it
he thinks that hypergamy consists of
this
women mate across and up
success hierarchies
but yet on tinder there's no real way to
say that there's any kind of success
because tinder is for one thing
which is hooking up it's for getting
laid jordan
as for the alpha seed or we at the armor
it's the alpha [ __ ] side of hypergamy
jordan
women want to get laid they're not all
sweetie honey bambi you know
you all little angels with with halos on
right even the girls in bible study
those chicks are on tinder too okay or
hinge or whatever the equivalent is okay
so when
when we talk
interesting so just because someone has
tender that's the alpha i'm gonna just
talk about um you know how how do women
select right that's that was the whole
thing about hypergamy now he's using
thank you jordan thank you thank you for
using the term like at least somewhat
properly here but he only focuses on the
beta bucks side of hypergamy there are
two sides it is dualistic there's the
short-term sexual benefits there is the
genetic benefits there's the hot guy in
the foam cannon party that guy looks
like the dude in the uh
in the hot fireman's calendar and i
really want to bang him he really gets
me off my arousal level is way up here
right that's women want to have sex
that's the validational side of
hypergamy
the sex she wants to have enthusiastic
consent there it is that's what that's
the sex she wants to have then there's
the beta bucks side which is exactly
what he just described here and most
guys particularly trad cons only
exclusively focus on this one side which
is oh they're they're success
hierarchies so women only pick guys who
are in the success hierarchy
no no they don't they go for guys that
they want to bang especially when
they're younger especially when they're
in that window between 18 and 28 years
old
hot guy in the foam cannon party jordan
that's what they're looking for at
that's certainly what they're looking
for on
tinder okay it's interesting because
i feel like girls look for a combination
of both
um like there's definitely attraction
too i think it'd be silly to say that
like attraction plays no
part in hyper mirror who girls tend to
pick
um
like very obviously
so i don't i don't even think jordan
peterson discounts that i just think
there's no real way to like measure that
maybe they're not looking for mr right
they're looking for the guy who's just
gonna rock their world and hope to god
that they can lock that dude down
with a great new technology called
hormonal birth control that we've
already mentioned too
so
so you've got that now
he also explains this he says you know
and then men mate across and down well
no no they don't they would very much
like to make up
in fact in fact that's really the whole
reason why guys want to do won't want to
get laid they want to they want they
don't want to
oh land whale
they don't want to die you know a
land beast or whatever
they want they want the girl who looks
like the centerfold and they will jump
they will do lots and lots of things to
make sure or improve their chances to do
so
if a guy can get above his sexual market
value like his smv level he's going to
do it in fact that's really the whole
point of the red pill in game is to be
able to sort of break out of like okay
i'm interested to know because you
always hear about guys will be able to
go down and because it's interesting see
saying that right but i've heard so much
in the red pill that guys are able to
like would rather go down in looks and
if the girl is like loyal um low body
count
whatever like qualities they're looking
for and on top of that when i did a poll
on my channel about was the x you loved
the most the most attractive one and it
was like 75 said no so when he says like
mate up i'm curious if it's just like
straight looks
um it'd be interesting to hear him go
more into that what is it uh you know
you only get what you've gotten if you
keep doing what you've done that's
it's not there yeah men don't have an
attraction floor and i've tried to make
this point and stress this point on so
many goddamn
podcasts that want to run me up the
flagpole for it charlie and ben but it's
true and here it is here it is here's
your here's your god here's your
demi-god jordan peterson saying exactly
that
they don't have a attraction floor
no one's ugly after 2 a.m they'll be
happy to get
your hair back
between sexual attention and
relationship attention for women
slump busting yeah you don't hear that
from women you hear that from guys
yeah was it a whale hunting you know
chubby chasing there ain't no chubby
chasing for women right you will find
here here's here's a really great
example of this you will not find
a dating site
for
in shape
fitness america pageant
model
women looking specifically for fat guys
regardless of socioeconomic status you
will not find those those sites
if they exist somebody needs to send me
the link to those here is a site that's
specifically designed for women looking
for fat dudes
no there's plenty of sites for women who
are looking for you know was it
executive introductions right they're
looking for a rich guy for sure because
you know you know why those exist
because tinder already exists
the executive introductions which is in
this case really you know going up the
socioeconomic ladder as far as hypergamy
is concerned yeah women want that but
they're usually looking for that when
they get to be 28 29 when they're start
ready to cash out of the sexual
marketplace when they hit their epiphany
phase yeah that's when that's when women
don't like okay tinder put you away and
now let's go over to uh executive
introductions and see if i can find me a
rich man with benefits
because i've had my fun
i'm done with that anymore i've
completed my journey of self-discovery
you know what i discovered about myself
i need a man with benefits at 29 years
old that's what i've discovered i think
being a trust fund kid
really puts me in like a different
position
because i don't
i don't need that stuff i don't even
have like access to it now but it's like
i know i don't need a guy to live off of
other than my dad
conveniently at the age of at the
average age of first marriage
28 29 somewhere there that's so
surprising it's that late if it was up
to me i would have been married like
three years ago to be honest
average age of first birth right around
the same time
coincidence i think not
but again
all comedy aside here what jordan and
not just i'm going to just pick on him
because a lot of people in the sort of
trad con idea idealists
think that they're happy to embrace
hypergamy but one side of hypergamy
which is the beta bucks side men need to
man up and they need to get a good job
and they need to be husband material and
they need to be a good father and they
need to prepare themselves for maturity
and life and they need to be they don't
want to be kiddults anymore and we can't
have them prolonging their adolescence
they've got to be men you know there's
plenty of sites and plenty of gurus who
are ready to teach you guys that too
because that's the only that's the only
side of hypergamy that even ever
registers in their brain
because god forbid we say women really
just want to have sex with the hot guy
in the foam cannon party
they want that hot alpha seed right
so we won't say that because that would
step on the little lady's toes and that
might be some unflattering truths
you know brought up as a i just i never
know what the manuscript means when they
mean alpha
because a lot of times like when i talk
to cheesh is that he said alpha is like
leadership but if that's leadership
doesn't leadership play into the beta
bucks side because you know if you're a
better leader you tend to make more
money and that goes back to
um
like the beta bucks but at the same time
like i feel like all he's saying is that
attraction is part of it
and that's like duh
the result of that
so we avoid that so now hypergamy is
defined by just the beta bucks side now
guys
you black pill doomers
here's your chance here's here's your
term
the only thing you focus on is the alpha
[ __ ] side of of hypergamy the only thing
you guys focus on is looks looks looks
uh maybe status oh does he have a 10
inch dick yeah okay i guess there's that
too
physicality physicality physicality
there's only one side of hypergamy to
those guys and that's the alpha [ __ ]
side it's never never the twain shall
meet or maybe it does but nobody cares
about it women don't care about those
guys or they're just using those dudes
right oh you're never going to get her
sexual best because she wanted to [ __ ]
chat in the foam cannon party
like that's all you focus on and then
that's all tradcon's focus on they never
want to say look there's alpha flux and
beta bug it's dualistic there's two
sides to it no one ever wants to talk
about or if they do they want to stress
one side over the other no i agree with
that there's like
looks play into it but so does um
like i mean so does being responsible
i'm looking for a guy that has like
certain qualities sure um it's
interesting the more i learn about rolo
the more he actually kind of makes sense
so let me know in the comments if you
guys are rolo fans um don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell and i'll talk to you
guys next time